jackie for more on the crisis at our
southern border let's bring in former
acting ice director and heritage
visiting fellow as well as fox news
contributor tom home and tom you just
heard brian genesis report there down an
eagle pass that sector they've had 1190
crossings in the last 24 hours they are
up 158
and it looks like title 42 is on the way
out what do you make of the situation
right now
well look it's only going to get worse
right i spent the last two days uh
getting angry at the tv set when the
secretary is is under all sitting in
front of congress saying the border is
secure the borders closed and we're
effectively managing this crisis
he lied under oath the first sitting
cabinet member
that i know that live under oath to
members of congress he lies everyday
american people you can't say the
borders closed and secure when he got
over seven hundred thousand got away you
can't say the borders secure when you
got nearly 700 migrants have died on u.s
soil making this trip you can't see the
border secure when there's enough
fentanyl come across this border that
that's killed
killed 112 000 people
you can't say the board is secure
when the mexican cartels are making bans
the mexican cartels control our southern
border drift we no longer control it and
a chief patrol agent told me he has lost
operational control on the border they
can't contain what's coming in right now
even with title 42 if they left title 42
it you know god help us
well and the projections are you could
have as many as 18
000 a day you ran ice you ran one of the
the border enforcement agencies what
does that do how does the border patrol
cbp ice how do they deal with something
like that well first of all we gotta
understand even with title 42 they've
arrested 42 people on the fbi screening
database that's what they arrested now
we know terrorists you know they try to
invade law enforcement they're trained
to do that so if they've arrested
fortitude successfully how many of the
700 000
are known as suspected terrorists border
patrols arrested people from 161
countries many of those countries
support terrorism so if anybody thinks
not a single one of the 700 000 came to
this country to do us harm they got away
then they're ignorant they're not
looking at it fast and look the title 42
they looked it i just said borch was
already overwhelmed just last month 67
000 got aways just in one month 67 000
got away we don't know who the hell they
even are so the this this immigration
crisis this humanitarian crisis this
public safety public health crisis is
turned into a national security crisis
and i'm angry with the secretary because
if he had a one ounce of integrity
he would call the white house say i no
longer can support this open borders
agenda because it's put this country at
great risk for terrorist attacks that is
just a stone cold fact so shame on him
for continuing to support the open
borders and shame on him for lying under
oath in front of congress
so tom what should congress do then do
do we hope that there is some bipartisan
effort to stop title 42 from lifting to
perhaps go after secretary marcus
oh look even with total 42 you know
the secretary said well that's that's a
cdc thing i can't control that but what
he can control is remaining mexico
program we sued him to put that back in
place i was a part of that lawsuit i've
written more affidavits for the state of
texas than i ever did as a special agent
so he's got to do the right thing for
the american people and and do their and
stand up and tell the white house no but
what congress can do is do what they did
the other day call this secretary out
call them out
and and hopefully we take the house and
send it back and impeach him he needs to
be impeached he needs to be removed he
has failed he has been in position for
15 months almost 16. the president's
been in position 16 months the numbers
keep climbing they haven't done a single
thing to slow the flow ever even now
with lifting title 42 they're going to
spend almost a billion dollars building
soft sided facilities to process and
release quicker which is just going to
tell the cartels bring more because
they're releasing it even quicker now
it's just everything they've done is to
it acts as a magnet and not a single
thing not one enforcement strategy to
secure that border
well tom we are less than 30 days away
from that date may 23rd of title 42
lifting we will shall see what happens
and what congress does if anything
between now and then tom homan thank you
for joining us